i feel like because black folks have
such a particular relationship with
their hair yeah they understand like how
important it is to maintain but they
also know how like
vulnerable and
weak people are when it comes to hair so
they'll use that and they'll weaponize
it against you immediately if you say
anything they don't like or if they
don't [ __ ] with you meaning like uh
if a black person wants to clown on a
black person the first thing they're
going to go to is hair yeah one of the
first things
you even got a hairline yeah we're the
only group that i know of that does that
yeah definitely and i think it's precise
because it's such a personal
[ __ ] with
like
your fate ain't right yeah and they get
dirty
all crooked and [ __ ] right
but the thing is i ain't never giving a
[ __ ] about my hair
never never
and so every time i got those comments
i'm like so do you know how much money i
say i'm not going to the barber i don't
care
is my [ __ ] to try to hurt the
[ __ ]
this one's trying to go factual yeah
actually according to my taxes yeah so
so i'm like if you want to climb me like
[ __ ] you don't even know how to save
money that would hurt my feelings but if
you say something about like oh bro you
don't even have a good i don't care i've
never been that dude but i know it
affects other folks a lot
it affects them a lot and that's why
folks always jump to that first [ __ ]
get your hairline straight it's funny
because when i was in high school i
would use to care about my hair like
just having my hair just having nobody
touch it yeah but like you said people
would claw me on my hair because my
hairline was [ __ ] i was like
yeah
mm-hmm yeah
and you know what is the least
offensive [ __ ] that you call me today so
i'm gonna take that
huh we're gonna talk about my hair
yeah yeah i could take that over the
other [ __ ] that you said to me so yeah
sure my hair
like it's not even just hair shoes
hair shoes clothes
but think about how shallow and vapid
that is
just like from a cultural standpoint i
feel like we're the only group of people
who does that
we don't we're not the only group of
people who does that but it's just when
we do it we we make it count because
people do look at
how dusty the clothes are or whatever
and stuff in other places it's just
we make it a huge thing other people are
going to look at how you look how you
how you present yourself you know
especially like whenever you
you get rich rich you know i mean
the simpsons had a whole a whole uh
episode about that when marge
starts to have rich friends
and then she had she bought that one
chanel suit right that was on rebate and
then every time she used to work
overnight to change it a bit and having
the pressure but a lot of people have
that i think women are an exception to
that i think women because they know how
much looks matters between each other in
terms of just mating and stuff like that
that they'll clown each other on their
looks sometimes when they're being petty
but maybe you can speak to this as an
arab man do you feel like there's such
an emphasis there's so much judgment on
clothing oh yeah tell us about that we
can't do hair because again this is
triggering i i go we all go bald bro
look at your hairline [ __ ] you ain't
got [ __ ]
it's such a switch that's wearing this
hat dude yeah
you like baseball i'm like no i'm i'm
ashamed of this
trying not to [ __ ]
look like uh my knuckleheads in your
shawarma you know yeah
um but clothing for sure but i was
always outside of that like i relate to
that too because
i didn't have a lot of money growing up
and i just never cared about that [ __ ]
because i couldn't afford to care about
it you know but def especially in
lebanese culture
talk to us you gotta have like it's a
specific look too you know
it's like it's based off uh
it seems like a kind of
their interpretation of like what cool
people in like milan or paris where you
know okay like
you gotta have like even if you're
wearing a t-shirt it's gotta be like
diesel or like
it's gonna be as they call it marca yeah
which means a brand you know brand names
you know
if i like i could tell right away the
immediate judgment
what do they say [ __ ] to you
they'll say [ __ ] behind your back i
think okay see uh yeah maybe that's the
difference i know yeah because i
definitely 100 agreed regards to
judgment they're super judgmental i
think most
[Music]
also there's probably also confirmation
bites because i feel like black folks in
social media we are so omnipresent yeah
so loud on social media it just seems
like it's a big feedback but it's a
reflection of what's going on in the
hood it's a reflection of what's going
on in our lives yeah i mean so yeah we
do climb up for the in our in their
faces yeah we have roast sessions like
we
we in high school you know you're done
eating and you're around the table the
cafeteria table
and
you just
roast
you just roast each other look at ass
yeah
i mean yeah i feel like i feel like with
ladies i feel like it's more of that
judgmental and then behind the back
thing too
but like black dudes or like even black
women sometimes you can come up to me
like
what's up with that hair like oh yeah
yeah yeah i'm just like who the [ __ ] are
you yeah
yeah in the car why do you care in the
comment section the comment section gets
wild very quickly they're very
aggressive wild yeah and it's almost
like
me not conforming to what they feel like
i need to look like
hurts them
you know what i'm saying or it bothers
them yeah because and i understand when
that's from you have to like first first
the thing about roasting each other and
looking good like that
you're not in the country that's yours
so it's like a flex on other
[ __ ] i made it
and then the second thing is like why it
hurts them yeah it looks and it sounds
like it hurts them because it actually
does
because you're gonna present yourself
like that to white people looking the
way you look then they're gonna think
that we all look like that all dusty and
[ __ ] fix yourself cause that [ __ ] hurts
me
then you're not gonna wanna hire a black
person because they dusty as [ __ ]
fix yourself you know what i mean that's
why like my parents say well
we we
always it's a collective thing
when i'm in the media when i'm in the
media i don't represent me
white people when they go in the media
they them
amber heard is amber heard
johnny depp is johnny depp when i go in
the media i'm a part of black people
yeah what will smith
chris rock that's black man yeah that's
a black man i give you something i [ __ ]
up if i [ __ ] up and i do some [ __ ] we
all [ __ ] up yeah we all what do we say
this [ __ ] set us back 10 10
years back that's fact we say that
we say that's a we say that
oh look at this [ __ ] he set us
back set us back he [ __ ] up he set us
back and that's the thing and that's the
reason why people are so like they feel
like they're hurt
when they they be trashing your hairline
my hair like whatever i'm wearing or
whatever you know what i mean
but when you do wear something fresh
they will congratulate the [ __ ] out of
you oh okay yeah is that you yeah and i
think i see you [ __ ] i think that's why
i don't i don't get hyped up on any of
the positive comments or any negative
comments because in the moment i do that
i become beholden to them i start
dressing according to what they want me
to wear what they want me to look like
you know what i'm saying so people tell
me to keep my hair i'm like i don't
really give a [ __ ] you'll tell me to yo
manage your hair i'm like listen i'm
just do what i want to do at any day
i think that's the only way to to live
semi-healthily because if you have to
conform all the time well that's where
we come to the next problem which is
like
all of a sudden every [ __ ] got the same
nose
everybody's got the same nose they got
the same lips it's like
and these are regular people it's not
even like they're instagram famous just
regular people but it starts with and
then i'm looking at the instagram
sometimes i'm like
you look like a hundred other women from
different countries who are about the
same nose yeah it's so crazy and that's
normalized that people don't even say no
[ __ ] about that no more that's just
normal a [ __ ] don't have his hairline
right everybody's like [ __ ] conform
but you guys are cutting up your faces
punishing your lips
underneath your eyes that are dangerous
injecting [ __ ] in your ass to all
conform to the same thing the people are
literally killing themselves yeah
to
appease what other folks are looking at
them for so for me that's why everyone's
like you don't care i don't care and it
should be more normal not to care it
should be more noble not to pressure
people to look like what you want
because guess what even though
everyone's conforming to these more
traditional beauty things you start to
realize it becomes stale it's like yeah
you're more conventionally attractive
but you're also boring looking
you know what i'm saying yeah it's like
i can't tell any of your cultural
heritage you've wiped this [ __ ] out
because you wanted to get rid of your
nose and rid of your face and your
cheekbone i can't tell like any like
where you're from or anything like that
you look like the next [ __ ]
there's nothing about you that's any
chocolate boy
i it's almost super sad
it's it's actually it's sad because
we also live in like the whole
a i do it for me culture it's just like
can we no you don't yeah no you don't
stop you cut yourself up for you zero
[ __ ] given yeah i feel like you gave a
little bit of that you came out the
woman said one day i want to look like
kim kardashian
you came out the womb and be like
where that kim k knows it that's what
you were saying i believe that you truly
don't give a [ __ ]
i do
i do and i'm not gonna say that like you
100 don't give a [ __ ] but you're the
most i don't give a [ __ ] that i've seen
i i definitely do give more of a [ __ ]
than you do that's definitely
so i don't i don't think i don't care at
all i'm not going to say it doesn't
affect me any type of way
but
i'll say that
i feel like my personal happiness
my personal peace of mind is more
important than anything
and anytime i've like made such a
conscientious effort
to look like what other folks wanted to
talk the way they did it made me
miserable i mean i dealt with that in
the military
shaving my head's not the issue
like the amount of conformity that they
demand like the the individualism that
they try to strip from you yeah
when i saw the negative sides that can
sometimes exist in that i vowed i would
never let that happen to me again i also
remember being in school
and like me immigrating from ethiopia i
always kind of been a bit of a loner in
that regards just like seeing how
everyone kind of lives just didn't make
any sense to me you know what i'm saying
so i'm like why am i going to repeat
what these people are doing like it
doesn't
it doesn't make me any happier
to act like them or to look like them
and they don't look happy so why am i
conforming to this i was always very
stubborn about [ __ ] like that the
clothes i wore and stuff like that i
wouldn't say it doesn't affect me i just
i hated what it felt like to have to do
what everyone else wanted me to
you know for the sake of that so that's
uh that's probably what i would say yeah
yeah
no it's like there's a there's like of
course there's like there's a spectrum
you know i mean there's people that
really don't give a [ __ ]
like to the point that i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm not gonna wash yeah i'm not
gonna wash i'm not gonna bathe i'm not
gonna take care of my [ __ ] because i
don't care about other people or
whatever you know i mean
there's to that extent you know what i
mean where you told
total disregard that's unhealthy though
yeah i'm pretty sure no not washing is
like not wash ever but there's a yeah
there's a where it's not gonna be
unhealthy but you know you
yeah
you stink you whoa
you smell like
you're past dude yeah yeah yeah yeah you
do
your due date as come
listen you gotta give a little bit of a
[ __ ] yeah you have to give a you have
that just a basic [ __ ]
they give you a basis this is your daily
basic [ __ ] that you have to give here
you go society that's my basic [ __ ] what
do you mean i bathe
yeah i wash my booty yeah yeah i brushed
my hands and you know what's funny is
that you'll see people with the finest
clothes who got some of the nastiest
hygiene that's always a trick
i'm like [ __ ] say what you want i be
showering all the time i'll be taking
care of my spot my place is semi-clean
like if you come in it don't look like
i'm trying to hide bodies somewhere okay
i take care of my [ __ ] i manage it i see
[ __ ] who outwardly look amazing
you go to their home it's churnable
it is insane to me that's
oh yeah this [ __ ] don't work and i'm
like okay yeah whatever uh i'll pass by
i'll pass by and then you pass by
yo gp put the three on put the camera
three on
you know when you step in the
[ __ ] house
you take your shoes off because you're
respectable yeah and then you walk two
three steps in the house and you have to
do this
to get the crumbs off your socks
[ __ ] let me put my shoes back on yeah
let me put my shoes back on because it's
less dirty outside yes
[Applause]
i don't want to make outside dirty with
your place
[Music]
and i'm gonna have to take off my shoes
when i step outside yeah let me be
considerate of this planet [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] no no no no
absolutely wait you ain't no walking in
my house
and it's like you you step inside people
you step it's not people's apartment and
you're like
you knew i was coming over right
no
you ever walked you ever walked into
somebody's apartment like
does the cat pay rent yo
the cat difference campaign
whatever the [ __ ] it was first and
foremost ha ha that i didn't even see
your cat i'm outside your house
[ __ ] it smells like cat
that's wild there's some of y'all out
there you like pets you shouldn't own
them
goddamn yes [ __ ]
yeah so let's see it
there's definitely there's definitely a
lot of folks who are friend with what
they
what with what they got brother i was a
cable guy once uh
nick you [ __ ] know we're coming
it's called an appointment
i mean do something
i don't know
a minimum
bruh hold up you know what i'm gonna
just say this right now for everyone
watching if you're in the comments leave
us a story at the time you were going to
go see somebody maybe a partner or a
friend
and they made like oh actually you about
to [ __ ] somebody for the first time
that's the best one
let me know of a time where you about to
[ __ ] somebody for the first time and
they made no effort to manage their
place [ __ ] is out of order it's not
happening i don't see it happening what
the [ __ ] that's wild bro i feel like
there's people who deal with that and i
need to hear their stories yes we want
we want stories i need to hear the
stories
drop that [ __ ] in the comment
differently i want to i will say look me
like i want problems
i i think me not being materialistic to
some degrees like been a big benefit
because i've like traditionally invested
more so in like experiences like i tell
you i don't like spending money but i'll
pay quite a lot for a nice airbnb
experience yeah yeah i'll pay i'll pay a
lot of money for like a beautiful
restaurant experience like my man abba
doesn't like things he likes experiences
yeah that's why i [ __ ] with sex workers
[Laughter]
i feel that way i am at it but also i
think you know just kind of keeping what
i have and just enjoying that also made
me more attached to the very few items i
did have like this jacket i didn't think
about bringing this up today this jacket
i've had it for seven years i know okay
and you guys can't tell you passed it up
it's been patched up meaning like it
started ripping look at the shuttle yeah
if you look at the shoulders here like
right here you can actually see it there
that's a patch that's a patch i had i
paid somebody
to literally patch up the swap you got
you got some clorox stain in the back
yeah yeah
like like it's time to retire this thing
but every now and then i pull it out
right that's why you and my dad you vibe
so much what you mean that's why you and
my you're my dad y'all mother you saw my
dad and he was like
this is a cool [ __ ] yeah yeah
but that that's how my dad be because
yeah my dad's going to be my dad is
going to be in the living room and he's
going to be like
and he's so so in he's sewing
my mom's like throw that jacket out he's
like no it's perfectly good
that's real though i get that because
you know
like it's funny since i started comedy
to to the point today this jacket has
seen me through so much i couldn't
afford a whole lot so even winter i used
to rock i know
cold canadian winters i used to rock
this and everyone's like where's your
jacket i'm like [ __ ] you looking at it
i got a sweater underneath but this is
it right and anybody who looks at this
would know that's not adequate but
for me like through experiences this
item has been with me through that whole
thing and so now when i look at it it's
like you're never gonna find a jacket
like this anywhere because it's
literally has experience on it ripping
from certain points from being overused
and overwashed or whatever it may be so
for me it's like a it's a cool memory to
look at certain objects as a result and
i think we live in such a consumer
society in ways that we just take
clothes we throw them out get the new
pair like how many times have people
been doing spring cleaning and throwing
out like hundreds of t-shirts they don't
give a [ __ ] about absolutely right and
so sometimes i feel like less can be
more in a lot of ways you know because
it's not very often that people have
clothes that make them feel any type of
way and the thing that happened is that
it's like it's like a biker mentality as
well like whenever we buy our cuts we
have a cut yeah we don't change that
[ __ ] no if we fall in this bruise [ __ ]
we fight we fail and it's bruised yeah
okay that's part of the history of what
it is yeah i got my cut and there's a
scuff on it and i'm like yeah that's in
2020 when i fell out when i fell down
with my bike yeah yeah i broke my ribs i
broke my yeah my shoulder blade i got
road rash right here right here yeah
yeah
it's history yeah so we keep it but more
so than that i know i am more
materialistic than you but when i bought
like when i buy a piece yeah like for
example that chinchilla coat yeah if
that chinchilla coat is getting ripped
we're fixing it right we're not throwing
it out
gotta kill the new chinchilla
get a patch on it somewhere chinchilla's
crying right now you know i mean no no i
hope he [ __ ] keeps his coat right
now
i'm trying to eat michael now we fixed
that [ __ ] i got another leather coat
that i just bought
the the thing the loop to to to hold the
the
the belt got loose yeah i went right
here
threw it off my back and i sue yeah and
i was like yo let me just you know just
like my dad showed me yeah you know
every time i but my my my my i remember
i was a kid kid
and my butt and one of my shirts got
ripped yeah and i was like uh it fell
like the shirt is no good no more i like
that shirt my dad put me aside it's like
nah man sure it's perfectly fine come
here let me show you i was like seven
years old it was like this is how you do
it yeah and then he showed me how to put
the button back in and then there's a
lot of people that didn't have that you
know what i mean so yeah that's why you
that's what i'm saying you were my vibe
you saw the vibe of my dad's like
yeah
yeah so here's another example what's up
i love my bed
i i could be in a relationship with my
bed
dead ass
i see my bed every night and i'm like i
missed you man
yeah yeah we got a great working
relationship and
the thing about my bed is it's not
perfect even the way i bought it
it like the whole circumstances where my
purchase would be here
if someone came to me tomorrow said i
can give you a better bed
100 you're gonna enjoy it more than this
bed i would still not let go
that's how much i like my feel what
you're saying i feel what you're saying
because i felt really comfortable in my
bed yeah okay but the minute you change
that [ __ ] and you get a good mattress
it should change your life to be fair
you thought you're confident you stopped
who we failed
to be fair
i've had other beds this bed is the best
i've ever had it's not even close like
sounds great
the best i've ever had
i've had women come over and be like yo
what the [ __ ] is this bad that's how
like nacho dig the beds
hey i came for the dick but i can't stay
for the bed
yo it started being a prop because
everybody wanted sleepovers right but
dead ass that's how you get them how did
i get what that's how you get girls yo
come in the room two seconds i want to
show you something yeah sit on the bed
ooh this is nice
i know
is that
that hot you get though no no it's not
it's not but it's not a bad pitch it's
not a bad pitch pillow talk
no so so i think just having things like
that that you can actually
live through and spend a lot of time
with people feel that way about certain
homes that they fixed up and had
memories in like things take on new
meaning when you give it time and you
actually
it's weird it's like i don't say it's
reciprocal because these inanimate
objects but you can grow attached to
certain things based off going through
things with them rather than always
thinking like let me update with the new
stuff let me get the new stuff let me
get the new stuff it's sometimes good to
just be chill what you got and you can
do a lot more with it i think
the thing will mean more than buying
five new things if that makes sense
it's like there's a new motorcycle that
just came out yeah i'm a fan of that
motorcycle that's the motorcycle i got
right but the motorcycle is a gen 2
right there's three generations right
now yeah and it's a wonderful suzuki
hayabusa and i have the gen 2 and now
the gen 3 just came out and i can buy it
like that right in the my one of my uh
garage guy
just bought
the gen 3. he has the gen 2 but he
bought a gen 3. and it's all souped up
and everything and i was like oh
man
[ __ ] it looks nice and new technology
and stuff like that
and then i just got back on my bike and
i was like nah i live this
is my [ __ ] yes this is this big [ __ ]
it's my [ __ ] right here that's why i
caught my bike big [ __ ]
big yeah
there's so much time and effort and ride
and memories and [ __ ] like that yeah
there's gonna be a time when you have to
move on but at least like you know
you've seen it i just i've had that bike
for like
three years yeah let me enjoy it a
little bit enjoy it let me just have
some fun respects man i mean but yeah i
get that sometimes you need to
make things last yeah it's worth it yeah
no your time is not due so whenever you
put another patch on your shirt i like
how you feel i like how it sits on you
yeah and stuff like that it's like scars
i i would not hide my skin exactly and i
embrace like the scars i have on my i
got a
whenever i do plato they always ask me
or do you want to us to hide them nah
man that's me no that that's me this
right here this right here this this me
yeah it's part of me yeah don't fix it
don't fix it show it i think and so that
comes back to the whole thing with with
the with the women in the surgery yeah
it's like i prefer looking at your oddly
shaped nose you because it's peculiar
it's you that's you that's yours that's
your generational face that's your
heritage don't run away from that my
girl was like yo i ain't got no lips i'm
like [ __ ] i do
yeah
you can't say me so we good yeah you
know that that's one thing that's so
overrated people always talk about i
mean like kissing big lips and all those
other stuff no it's literally it's over
kissing a good kisser is kissing that's
good that's it
trust me the best kisses i've ever had
didn't have lips like that it don't
matter i don't know why that's been my
experience
it don't matter did you see the lips and
you like
it's not worked out that way at not it
depends how they work it but it's not
necessary one doesn't equate to the
other it doesn't mean that big lips is a
good nah no you could be just fine like
that is the moment that count
[ __ ] thing like oh it's like
saying oh i mean that's a fat pump yeah
that's it yeah yeah i mean yeah
what about you have any objects uh
things that i'm attached to yeah there's
certain it sounds ridiculous but there's
like socks
i am mad at you
they're still in good shape i'm not like
i don't got like hold socks or something
yeah but sometimes when you have an
experience like for example like there's
socks i'm wearing right now yeah where i
had like
one of the best sets of my life in
comedy you know okay and part of me
thinks of that every time i put them on
really today i want it to be a good day
it's mother's day
i put on my good socks
trying to make my mom laugh a bit and
bring her some joy you know yeah that's
dope so
yeah there's certain pieces of i'm like
you i don't buy a lot of clothes and i
like when i find and i'm a big guy you
know so it's like hard to find stuff
that fits so when something finally fits
you keep it for a while but yeah for me
it's experiences i've had in that
clothing sometimes i was like yo i won a
comedy competition in that shirt that
shirt stained sometimes i'll just i know
it's gonna
eventually get ratty so i just like i
won't wear it quite as much right you
know girl sometimes she's talking [ __ ]
about sometimes i got holes in my my
t-shirts and stuff
and she's like man throw it out i'm like
hey hey hey i didn't ask your opinion
yeah i i didn't ask you if hey there's
holes in it it's part of me those holes
are part of me i didn't ask you for
nothing all right yeah all right because
that does this no you ask me then i
answer it right and ask you why is your
business that's how the style got
started
yeah the whole jeans wasn't a fashion
statement at first it was just it's poor
people who didn't buy new things no they
were like hey
and then it became a fashion trend like
sagging pads too right
uh psychopaths from prison
i don't know if that's a myth
is that a myth i don't know if i've been
telling people for years i don't know i
don't know if that's a million dollars
didn't see that
i saw i didn't see i didn't see that
[ __ ] sagging their [ __ ]
yeah and it came from prison yeah saying
that you know you have alabama
yeah yeah so you just see like a lot of
trends are born from like
just poor people's like everyday habits
but that's just a way of saying that you
don't care there's a fashion that is you
you're not carrying sure the holes in
the jeans is like you are not confirming
to you having home you're not supposed
to have to wear some things and
to wear some things with holes in them
and you're like nah you know what i
don't care that's what i'm going to put
that's really it's if you think about
the first time that folks wore really
baggy clothes i'm pretty sure they
didn't do it because they thought it was
cool and fashionable they did it because
either they inherited those clothes from
their bigger siblings so they couldn't
like so you think about these trends but
they're trying to rock it in a way that
yeah yeah yeah even the skinny jeans
like i bet you anything at first when it
started somebody who's like listen this
is what i got and i'm a rocket and i
don't care especially in hip-hop and
hip-hop like first when the hip-hop came
out like the 70s and stuff like that it
was main street [ __ ] were
wearing the tightest [ __ ] yeah like tied
it like leathers and spandex and [ __ ]
like that and crop tops i've seen that
i've seen that it was part of hip-hop
[ __ ] like nah i'm a true
hip-hop head i like hip-hop from back in
days uh [ __ ] when back in the
days okay be specific yeah and then when
the 80s came and the girls were rocking
baggy clothes i'm like no this is the
jacket of your mans yeah it's your man's
jacket but you just rocking it like that
yeah yeah and then it the style came up
came about i'm pretty sure i want to put
100 on it but yeah when you inherit
things from your bigger brother you
don't quite fit you know
yeah i never really jumped on either
trends i think like for me i've always
kind of been in between so i've always
been comfortable with that but i think
when i when i think about raising kids
and having children my own and like kind
of
one i
want to impart on them i never want them
to think that
whatever sense of individualism that
they have isn't necessarily a bad thing
or where they want to go with things or
i want to encourage and foster that as
much as possible
you know
and um i think the only way you can do
that in a way that's like really
effect effective is to live that
yourself
you know
i think we've had this conversation but
it's like it's hard to tell your kid to
like love themselves as they are
when you've cut up your face so many
times yeah absolutely
it's like oh yes you're perfectly what
we are
mom i think what about you
let's not talk about that like how do
you justify that you know how how do you
justify that you know how do you tell
your kid it's okay to be short if you
got in height surgery like yeah that's
going to be a hard one to sell
kids look at your actions before they
listen to your words
you know
and i know i i love all these feel-good
messages that everyone says which pretty
much alleviates any accountability
people have for their choices it sounds
great nobody needs to be responsible
cool when you pass it on to folks who
don't care for any of that who see how
you actually move
they know it's [ __ ] we all know it's
[ __ ] yeah there's a lot of things
like about the
botox right now you're not supposed to
ask a woman is like or top comments i
seem like a
bad personality like yeah uh
it's not in your business what we put in
our faces and stuff like that and i'm
like i concur
okay
concur it's not of her business cause
there's some people that will go out of
their way to ask oh my gosh she needs to
slack on the botox she needs to slack on
the lip fillings and lip fillers and
stuff like that yeah concur it's none of
nobody's business i understand that but
then when you turn around and you got a
kid not having confidence in there and
and there's stuff because they look at
you and they look at the mirror and
they're like [ __ ] i don't look like that
how you gonna make
that's the that my mom look good i don't
look like my mom i don't look good
so how are you gonna explain that to
your kids it's hard it's not even even
as a man man started to have like men
are starting to have more and more
surgeries and stuff like that and he's
like yeah how how you're gonna same same
same like it's more prevalent with women
but even with men it's starting to be
like more like that hair transplants are
everywhere now huh hair transplants yeah
how am i gonna
give me a number bro yeah i can put you
in touch with some people if you want to
go to turkey
okay
i think it involves them like literally
poking a bunch of things and they
literally implant hair yeah transplant
that's what it translates yeah that's
what they take your hair out but it's
just like they're poking a bunch of hoes
like they would take
hair out of your ass we'll see yeah and
you know i mean you got bad hair
everywhere so you'll be fine
you're picking any body parts who
doesn't
you don't got no hair on jazz
dang that's what i i confirmed yeah
everybody got here um but some some
people got more hair than others on the
whole thing it's not yours
i think that's funny when people say
it's not your business because to me
it's like on one hand folks blame
society for any beauty standards that
folks have to conform to on the other
hand it's nobody's business it's like
those two things can't exist at the same
time no right like
you are making choices as a result of
society but the society cannot comment
on the choice you're making no what
happens
no that makes sense and also
i hate the fact that everyone's so tone
deaf about this stuff or they're just
like we're not talking about it because
i'm like
these beauty standards are not born in a
vacuum no they're coming from somewhere
that is a societal thing that we're
absolutely and nobody was trying to look
like this 30 years ago all right and
nobody just sprouted this idea from no
[ __ ] nowhere and then everyone else
on instagram had the same idea so
clearly there's a tremendous amount of
influence involved in pushing people to
do these choices so we should be having
constant discussions about that i'm not
here to be ragging on individuals and be
like you [ __ ]
i don't care like that go do whatever
you want to do at the end of the day
it's your choice but let's talk about
what these things mean in a greater
context
and think about what are we pushing
people to do because this people getting
surgery as younger and younger i know
women going to [ __ ] random hotel
rooms in atlanta and getting horse
needles in the ass
bbl's most dangerous surgery right now
in the world absolutely so many people
are dying from them so it's like we
should be talking about them it's not
it's not none other than business i
don't have to go in on you as an
individual i'm not trying to shame any
one person i'm talking about what does
this mean and where are we going yeah
because i think just to finish my last
point yeah go ahead in five years
ain't nobody gonna have the original
faces no definitely not
what
i'm speaking to ladies specifically you
know on instagram and you like
i thought i knew you who's this that's
what it's going to be absolutely and
it's
you can't be outraged at these little
girls out there
that feel the way they feel with their
body and they're doing all types of
things you know either mutilating or
themselves or or or doing like bulimia
or
making themselves throw up and having
all these things in your face
you're part of the problem you're
promoting that
the beauty sensors and [ __ ] like that
well you're doing the same thing
you cannot be outraged and be like you
know what there's little girls out there
oh it's really [ __ ] up we need to do
something and blame the magazines and
stuff like that when you post yourself
with your face that is fixed yeah you
could be like you could be talking [ __ ]
about the kardashians and stuff like
that because they're
they're using all these fillers and
they're using all these filters and
stuff like that but you do the same
thing you are also part of problem you
are contributing so
here's the weird part about this i feel
like everyone is both
the victim and the perpetrator yep
and that's possible yeah that is
possible i mean you cannot have these
beauty standards and not be the victim
to because you have to conform to
something so yeah you know what i'm
saying you didn't come up with the euro
so you were also afraid of that
you know so that's i think the reason
why i don't condemn individuals because
i'm like yes you perpetuate it but
you're also a victim to it
you have to have enough insecurity in
you and regress to how you look
to feel like i'm gonna only feel better
if i conform to that that means you're a
victim of this whole thing right
uh but at the same time via that choice
and you
publicizing it to everyone you are then
telling everyone like yeah you
i did it for me i feel better
that's what most people do plastic
surgery do all of a sudden they start
taking new photos
you face new me
oh yeah same instagram handle though
it's [ __ ] up because i got a girl i
know
i know of her we all know her like that
and this [ __ ] got two bbls and
she said like i almost died of the
second one i'm like [ __ ] two bbs
two of them
two of them yeah girlfriend two of them
one for each cheek or like
i don't know i didn't get the the
i didn't get the details about that but
i was like girl
two of them yes that's [ __ ] two
like one was god damn i wouldn't anyways
a hundred percent wouldn't recommend but
hey if you got to do whatever you got to
do do it do it it's never enough for
some people that's the thing you know
it's like well after after almost dying
i think it's enough for her but i don't
know like
but it's like yeah even the
breast implants breast implants can
cause cancer look it up yeah
all the silicone in your body your your
body consumes all that silicone it
transferred to your body and then you
your body start acting weird yeah you
develop different symptoms and [ __ ] like
that yo
yo this ain't
you do do what you got to do but
but we're not supposed to judge yeah you
were saying
i think often with people they get
multiple
you know it seems like once you
start on that train it's like
very few people are like oh no i'm good
yeah you know one surgery this is the
face yeah you know yeah no it's always
like you know what the lips could be a
little bigger because it doesn't last
also the the like it doesn't last the
lips don't last well nothing lasts the
boom don't last the bbl don't laugh if
you think like you're gonna get uh
uh
fat transfer or whatever and stuff and
you're just going to be good and not go
to the gym no
if you want that thing you have to
entertain that thing and if you don't
and even if you do not think that thing
gonna drop yeah oh yeah so it doesn't
last like we talk about a lot of we talk
about a lot for women but yeah man too
yeah i think
in talking about that i think
the where it comes from is also
interesting because i think men promote
this idea of excess as well
you know like let's keep it a stack
bbl's are popular because hip-hop
definitely and [ __ ] just kept going
more and more and more definitely and
this is comes back to the original thing
where it's just like we are a culture of
excess
more clothes more items more women more
ass more gold more more bling more
more drip more everything everything is
more
right titties get bigger the better yeah
yes bigger the better
even it looks crazy
you got women who can't lay on their
back because it makes a lay on the back
because the bbl is so big it makes their
arch their back arch and so they have
back problems they have to they have to
this can't lay on her back that's the
surgery she paid for to get back
problems think about that you like this
and you're like i'm dying that's crazy
it's ironic because she might have got
it so she could be laying on her back a
little bit more yeah
i want to get laid on my back a little
bit more but i can't lay on my back
that's a lot right so
we are a culture that has encouraged
access so much and women are not you
know exempt from that that that
influence there it's like you want a man
you see what all the men are posting
you're looking at like that influences
you because ain't nobody talking about
no [ __ ] bbl's 30 years ago
[ __ ] was trying to lose their
ass yeah what was the name of that
magazine you know the king magazine
remember that i don't remember that i
didn't watch there was a magazine named
king magazine yeah it was like yo it was
there's a magazine called some and
that's for white people mostly yeah and
there's one one called it was called
king magazine yeah where you first saw
coco and him yeah the the the wife of uh
iced tea and stuff and it started like
that yeah it was more and more and more
yeah we
we're definitely part of that yeah so
we've been talking about women all the
time like that they they're not stuck in
traffic they traffic
we we signaling yeah you know i mean so
we're the reason there's traffic part i
think definitely part of it i think
that's why for me i've never
i'm so glad i never bought into the
whole excess thing like i'm fine with
little titties i'm fine with little ass
i like it all right i like it all right
come in whatever shape and size you got
let's get it popping you get what i'm
saying little lips no lips whatever it
is i don't mind
i've been i've been with every body type
possible i do not yes all of them oh big
big b big big big oh yeah yeah
i haven't done that too many times but i
have done it once
it's uh it's a different thing
yeah yeah it's a different thing so i'll
just say that but
why you talking about blood hey
say it
say it
this motherfucker's making calculations
and z
yeah it's just it's it's a lot to manage
it's it's a lot that's all that's all
i'm gonna say
i'm gonna keep it classy today you gonna
keep it classy yeah yeah i might dress
dusty but i keep the classes
i just um
i think it's good to encourage people to
just do
their thing
yeah that's probably what i would say so
i'm out of that i think we can end there
yes sir
dusty but classy